شهدت تركيا اسوا زلزال يعصف بها على مدى
قرن من الزمان فما هي التداعيات
الاقتصاديه التي عصفت بالاقتصاد التركي
جراء هذا الزلزال كشفت وكاله انباء
الاناضول التركيه ان هذا الزلزال اثر بشكل
كبير على الاوضاع الاقتصاديه لنحو 13
مليون ونصف مليون شخص في عشر ولايات تركيه
وافادت اداره الطوارئ التركيه ان الزلزال
دمر نحو
5775 مبنى هذا وتراجعت الليره التركيه عقب
الزلزال الى مستوى منخفض جديد امام
الدولار قبل ان تستعيد عافيتها وذكرت
وكاله ديمير اورين التركيه الخاصه ان مطار
اضنه بجنوب تركيا اغلق امام الرحلات
الجويه حتى اشعار اخر كما توقف تدفق النفط
الخام عبر خط الانابيب الواصل الى ميناء
جيهان على البحر المتوسط قبل ان يستانف
نشاطه مجددا وقالت شركه بوتاش التركيه
لتشغيل خطوط الانابيب بان تدفقات الغاز
الطبيعيه توقفت الى مناطق غاز عنتاب
وهاتاي وقهرمان مارش وبعض المناطق الاخرى
نتيجه الاضرار التي لحقت بخط نقل
وكشفت هيئه الملاحه البحريه التركيه ان
ميناء اسكندرون الواقعه للبحر الابيض
المتوسط بجنوب البلاد تضرر جراء هذا
الزلزال القوي وعلى اثر الزلزال قامت
بورصه اسطنبول باتخاذ اجراءات استباقيه
فاوقفت التداول على اسهم ثمان شركات كما
توقف الانتاج على نحو واسع في مدينه غازي
عنتاب وذلك تخوفا من حدوث هزات ارتداديه
خلال الساعه القادمه ياتي ذلك فيما توقعت
هيئه المسح الجيولوجي الامريكيه ان
الخسائر الاقتصاديه جراء زلزال ستتعدى
مليار دولار